[Music]
in the structured forms hitherto
considered which are distinguished in
general as consciousness
self-consciousness reason and spirit
religion
too as consciousness of absolute being
as such
has indeed made its appearance although
only from the standpoint of the
consciousness
that is conscious of absolute being but
absolute being in and for itself the
self-consciousness of spirit
has not yet appeared in those shapes
with paragraph 672
we are now starting a
new section of the phenomenology of
spirit
it is called religion and it occupies
most of the paragraphs left in the work
the only other
main section is the very short absolute
knowing at the very end of the work
which brings everything to
a conclusion so you might
ask yourself a number of different
questions about this
why is hegel waiting
until now to thematize religion
why why is this last section devoted to
that
and what's its relationship with the
philosophical enterprise with absolute
knowing
and with everything that that happened
before now
in this preliminary section
of religion before he starts getting
into the dialectical
advances and developments with with
natural religion religion
and art and then the revealed religion
he's going to tell us a bit about its
relation to
the previous progressions
here he calls them what miller has
translated as
structured forms gestaltungen so not
just
gestalten right not just shapes of
consciousness which he's going to talk
about quite a bit in this
this preliminary section but
you could call these formations
right processes where we move from
one gestalt into another gestalt into
another gestalt
and we need to answer the question well
why did we have to go through all this
other stuff
before getting to religion
and so here's part of the answer is
being provided
in this paragraph he's going to
distinguish religion
from these other main
quite lengthy sections he says
in the structured forms hitherto
considered so in all the rest of the
work right
a very large portion of it which are
distinguished
in general which are distinguished from
each other in general which we call
in general consciousness but with sign
uh self-consciousness zelda voice sign
reason fernand and then spirit
geist right religion too
as consciousness of absolute being and
such
has indeed made its appearance so he's
telling us we've we've seen
religion popping up in places
in the stuff that we've been studying so
far
now we should pause for a moment and
look at what he tells us about
religion he's not defining it here at
this point but he is
certainly characterizing it
consciousness
of absolute being the being there is not
zion the being there is vasen
right which can also be translated as
essence
and so you know something that is
essential something that is important
it's also absolute meaning that it is
unrestricted it is not relativized it is
not
qualified although in the ways that we
are going to see religion coming up in
the determinate shapes that it occupies
it is it is not going to be
absolute although its object will be
absolute in that way
so he tells us right that religion
has made its appearance but only
from the standpoint of the consciousness
that
is conscious of absolute being
absolute you know raisin in this case
so what does that mean for what was
going on within these
these structured forms you know
more was going on than we were realizing
as we were
making our way through those
progressions and this is you know a bit
of a side note
and it's in in some ways a side note
about side
passages you know going through hegel's
dialectic
there's always more going on at any
given moment
than meets the eye or meets the eye of
the reader
in going through the text our attention
is focused on one thing
and there's other developments happening
sometimes those feed
into the developing dialectic as we go
down the path
sometimes they just you know get brought
up and
they don't get followed out or they do
much later on they re-emerge and each of
the processes so far
consciousness feeding into
self-consciousness which is a new
progression
feeding into reason which is yet a newer
and much longer and more robust and
concrete progression
reason feeding into spirit which is even
longer more robust
more complex more concrete right all
concrete you know is a rather relative
term when we're talking about
hegel we should point out because a lot
of this may have seemed very abstract to
you when we were going through it
but each of these had moments
where something wasn't quite realized
but could have been
referenced so hegel hagel's talking
about this
here he tells us that
absolute being in and for itself
the self-consciousness of spirit has not
appeared
in those shapes it has not appeared
in those progressions now that's kind of
a weird thing to say isn't it
because we just saw at the very end of
spirit that spirit was aware of itself
in this sense and that's how god entered
into the picture
well right but then now we're
transitioning to religion
so we can ask ourselves
is hegel being completely accurate in
his assessment of what he's gone through
at this point and the answer is probably
no
but because we've certainly had a
glimpse you could say of absolute being
in and for
itself as the self-consciousness the
self-consciousness of spirit
you know spirit has been using us and
the previous people throughout all these
developments
in order to develop itself to get
consciousness of itself
and so we've certainly had some some
glimpses
we we haven't ever grasped absolute
being in and for itself
in any of these things and i should
point out by the way
for those people who are like you know
hegel is primarily about the master
slave dialectic
that's way back here and that is a
rudimentary
shape of consciousness even in the
self-consciousness thing
it's definitely not grasping the
totality of things that is not the
master key for understanding hegel any
more than forcing the understanding is
in consciousness
any more than all the you know
interesting things happening in reason
or spirit
are none of those are the single
hermeneutic
for grasping hegel if anything
religion is going to provide that
hermeneutic
before we go on and look at the passages
yet to come that flesh out this
progression
and this idea about what's going on with
religion there's two things we we really
need to mention
you notice that that i'm drawing arrows
from religion to spirit reason
self-consciousness
and consciousness and that some of the
arrows are
dotted arrows why did i do that to
graphically represent
something about where we're headed
the consciousness section it has a
connection to
religion it has a connection you can say
to absolute being and for itself
it doesn't so do do so in a way that
is religious and so you could say the
object is being gestured at or pursued
but it's not being pursued in the
modality in the form
right of religion self-consciousness the
self-consciousness section as hegel's
going to point out in just a minute
in another paragraph that actually does
have a lot of discussion of religion of
actual religious practice on the part of
people
and theorizing about it in the unhappy
consciousness you could even say that
it's implicit there in the stoicism
section although hegel doesn't really
draw that out
reason same thing reason does not really
have much to say
by way of human religions spirit
if you've been paying attention spirit
did so
that's an important point the last thing
i want to say
before jumping into the next paragraphs
is we we it is a legitimate question
why is hegel bringing up religion in a
thematic way now
so this is a bigger you know broader
issue within hegel's thought hegel
thinks that
religion and philosophy
have a similar ground but
approach the objects that they're
working with in
different modes so religion is
particularly focused
uh when it's doing its job well on what
he calls picture thinking for stellang
right
representation is another translation of
it whereas genuine philosophy
when it's not merely a philosophy of the
understanding as he criticizes for
example lock as being
but it becomes a philosophy of the
concept or
as what miller translates as the notion
the the
uh the griff right and so it's
like a conceptual in a way that is
different than what other people have
called
concepts in in the past or ideas or
whatever and philosophy and religion
therefore they not only share a lot of
the same ground
religion is something that allows
world spirit in its concrete forms to
develop
certain ways of thinking which then
religion
can pass off to philosophy
and this is what you know in an article
i've actually called the second
enlightenment hegel
is kind of down on what we typically
call the enlightenment because it made
mistakes in relation to religion
throughout a lot of baby with the with
the bath water right
and he's also proposing something like
a philosophizing of religion
a taking religious concepts and
transforming them
into something more genuinely universal
more
genuinely self-aware and therefore
transforming religion in the process
as we're going to see happening in
particular in the revealed religion
section so that's all by way of
preamble about where we're going with
this section
even consciousness insofar as it is
in the understanding is consciousness of
the supersensible or the inner side of
objective existence
but the supersensible the eternal or
whatever else it may be called is devoid
of self
it is only to begin with the universal
which is a long way yet from being
spirit
that knows itself is spirit then there
was the self-consciousness that reached
its final shape in the unhappy
consciousness
that was only the pain of the spirit
that wrestled but without success to
reach out into
objectivity the unity of the individual
self-consciousness
and its changeless essence to which the
former attains
remains therefore a beyond for
self-consciousness
the immediate existence of reason which
for us
issued from that pain and its peculiar
shapes
have no religion because the
self-consciousness of them knows
or seeks itself in the immediate present
in paragraph 673 hegel is going to talk
about the first
three main courses or
progressions within the phenomenology
and
whether we attain to understanding
religion religion remember to is a human
orientation towards
absolute being or absolute essence that
is
in some way conscious of itself as doing
so did we actually attain to that
in any of these sections and
let's actually start by talking about
the one that he considers third
reason he says the immediate existence
of
reason which for us issued from that
pain the pain
of the unhappy consciousness which we'll
talk about in just a moment
issue and it's peculiar shapes it's its
particular gestalton right
have no religion because the
self-consciousness of them
knows or seeks itself in the immediate
present gegenvart what is what is there
for it and this this gigan is going to
be kind of
important here in just a minute
as we're going to see so the the whole
reason section as he says has no
religion
we should remind ourselves of what that
reason section the second longest
in the work actually comprise so when
you look at the
table of contents we start out with the
certainty and truth of reason
you know issuing after the
self-consciousness section
and here hegel distinguishes what he
means from idealism from other forms of
idealism
then he turns immediately to observing
reason and observing reason it doesn't
really need religion as a matter of fact
religion could be kind of a handicap
because it wants to
look at the world and figure out how
things
actually work and it is going to be
approaching
what hegel is calling the super sensible
or the inner side
of objective existence but it's it's
it's approaching it as something
that we the human subject can know and
delve into and grasp for ourselves and
then communicate about and
have science of viscense shaft right
so he's got all this stuff about you
know biological
organisms and the organic and things
like that
this is also the part where we have his
critique
of logical and psychological laws and
the
pseudosciences of physiognomy and
phrenology
none of that has anything to do with
religion and then he moves on
and and this is for me the stuff that's
really interesting in the reasons
section
uh the section following that is the
actualization of rational
self-consciousness through its own
activity
there he's talking about essentially
ethics in a broad
sense right what motivates the
human being what gives its life meaning
and he talks about the zakazelpst and
that
that whole passage well that whole
progression
the the thing it's no longer just the
thing in itself it's what preoccupies us
where we find
our good and he's got pleasure of
necessity the law of the heart and the
frenzy of self-conceived virtue in the
way of the world
and although virtue may be talked about
by religion you don't have to
think of things in a religious way at
all in that section
then we have the third section of reason
individuality which takes itself to be
real in and for itself and he's got this
whole discussion of what he calls the
spiritual animal kingdom and deceit
the matter in hand itself and then these
two things that are clearly
connected with kant in some way but also
with other philosophers
reason is law giver reason is testing
laws
no need to talk about religion in any of
that right
so the reason section is not one
that we're particularly worried about
thematically as giving us
content that is religion although we're
going to see that
we're not leaving reason totally behind
it's still important in relation to
these other sections
now let's look at the other two where
there's at least some
content hegel says so we come back to
the beginning of the paragraph
even consciousness in so far as it is
the understanding
is consciousness of the super sensible
or inner side of objective existence so
consciousness had three sections sense
certainty we begin from what seems to be
most simple most immediate most
straightforward we find out it's
actually quite complex
and that you know we can't even identify
the here and now
or then and there uh very easily and
then we move into perception and and
there it's about you know
the understanding coming into play but
also essences
and deception going on and we talk about
the thing in its properties
then we get to this this probably the
most challenging
part of the phenomenology i would say
from my experience
and from what people tell me about their
own readings
force and the understanding where you
know we've got a number of different
things coming in the concept of force
and force is in relation to each other
the human understanding is grasping
those forces
the concept of laws that are making
sense of those forces and
are able to be understood by the
understanding and
even a set of worlds including an
inverted world but but
there's really three worlds there that
all connect up together and give us the
world
that we know and can experience so here
hegel talks about the
super sensible or inner side
now super sensible you know we're
tempted to read that if we didn't have
that inner side
as like you know the supernatural the
transcendent what it is that's
above us but hegel's got his finger on
the right thing here
it's not just like what transcends us
it's what
is imminent within our experience
but we're not attending to because we
focus too much on
you know like the concepts not real
concepts in the hegelian sense but
you know the ideas the essences the
things that we encounter and we don't
really think about their
true significance and how they're bound
together in something
greater than them which our minds can
grasp the inner side
of objective gegensten lika
and so this is important and this is you
know this is tying in with what religion
is interested in it's not framed in a
religious way
in force in the understanding but
there's also a problem there as well
according to hegel
he says that the super sensible
the eternal aviga right or whatever else
it may be called
is devoid of self it is only to begin
with the universal which is a long way
yet from being spirit
that knows itself as spirit now it is
spirit right because everything is
spirit
but it's not spirit that knows itself as
spirit
it's intellect or understanding
grasping forces grasping laws grasping
the world
grasping its own role in doing so which
is all really cool stuff
but it's not yet spirit grasping itself
and what it's grasping is as he says
devoid of self it may be dynamic
but it doesn't have a self it doesn't
have subjectivity
it doesn't exercise intentional agency
which is what spirit will be doing
that's part of what it is when we talk
about there being
a god to to engage with to to worship to
be connected with
seems a little bit more promising when
we look at what we got out of
self-consciousness
doesn't it so hegel goes on and he tells
us
then there was the self the
self-consciousness that reached its
final shape gestalt right in the
unhappy consciousness which was a long
section in the self-consciousness
portion right we had that first
like thing about life and
self-consciousness and they encounter
each other
and you know self-consciousness exists
only through another self-consciousness
you're all familiar with that schtick at
this point
then we have the very short master slave
dialectic then we have the longer
stoicism
and skepticism sections which are
attempts to try to
figure things out to make sense of the
social world
that we're in they go beyond the master
slave dialectic but they don't totally
escape the problematic and then we have
the much longer unhappy consciousness
which is where self-consciousness
ends right and so self-consciousness the
whole section doesn't end
with me related to you and us struggling
to understand each other
it ends with me and you trying to
understand
god trying to understand the eternal
trying to understand the divine trying
to understand that which is
essential in relation to which we are
non-essential we are less important we
are
mere worms to use one phrase at a
certain point
so he talks about the pain of spirit the
schmerz
disguised us right this this sadness
this this
problematic that uh we're running into
and he tells us that um
in this we have the pain of the spirit
that wrestled
to reach out into objectivity gage and
stanley kind
so now notice we have objective
existence gegenstendliche design right
we have
objectivity itself gage and stanley kite
being
objective the state of being able to be
grasped as
an object the subject is is trying to
grasp god
in that way and that's why it has all
the smells and bells the incense prayers
all these are attempts
to reach the god who is
beyond he tells us that it's without
success
right not attaining what it is
attempting to do
it does advance spirit in the process
because even by not attaining it
it does attain certain shapes which just
are not
adequate to it and so hegel will tell us
that the unity of the individual
self-consciousness
and its changeless essence to which the
former attains
remains therefore a beyond for
self-consciousness now
remains a beyond it already was
a beyond that was trying to be brought
into objectivity by the worshiper
by the person who's trying to connect
themselves with god
god is already yanez zeitz on the other
side
beyond us and we reach towards god and
god
goes even further away we attain to a
spot and we're like finally i've got it
and then that's not god we're not
getting
what we're ultimately seeking this by
the way this concept
of human beings projecting part of
themselves
that they don't recognize as themselves
out there
on to god or whatever the religious
object is
as something that is then accorded
absolute value and you keep trying to
reach that is the interpretation of of
religion
by the great hegelian foyerbach right
hegel is gonna himself think that we can
move
past at least that conception
of religion that we're getting in the
unhappy consciousness
right so we want to find a way to unify
the individual self-consciousness
and changeless essence in religion so
what he's done for us in this paragraph
is told us
why we didn't get to religion as
religion
in these first three uh
important portions of the work which
comprise about half of the work
right
on the other hand in the ethical world
we did see a religion namely the
religion of the
underworld it is the belief in the
terrible
unknown knight of fate and in the
humanities of the departed spirit
the former is pure negativity in the
form
of universality the latter is the same
negativity in the form of individuality
absolute being is in the latter form
indeed the self
and present since other than present the
self cannot be
but the individual self is this
individual shade which is separated from
itself the universality which fate
is true it is a shade
a superseded particular self and thus a
universal self
but the negative significance of the
shade has still not
changed round into the positive
significance of the universal self and
therefore
the superseded self still has at the
same time
the immediate significance of this
particular and
essenceless being but fate devoid of
self remains the unconscious
night which does not attain to an
imminent differentiation
nor to the clarity of self-knowledge
paragraph 674 continues the discussion
the examination of the degree to which
religion
in the sense that hegel is is developing
it
in this this second to last section of
the phenomenology
has been involved in the four previous
parts and this one focuses
on the spirit portion that we've we've
just
concluded and it's it's looking at the
first part of the spirit section so
we're not looking at morality
which is the part that we just finished
up with we're also not looking at
culture which is going to have some
discussion
about religion particularly in terms of
faith or belief glaube
instead hegel is concentrating on the
discussion within the ethical order you
may remember
that he brought up the
particular case uh which he's you know
developing into something a bit broader
of the antigone and the battle between
uh the various you know children of of
uh oedipus
so he's drawing some some greater
conclusions about that
in that section in the ethical order
section we have a lot going on
and if we look at the actual titles
right
we have the true spirit the ethical
order this is coming after the reason
section which hegel has just told us
didn't have religion at all
the ethical world human and divine law
man and woman is the first part so human
and divine law
is the key part there well if you've got
divine law you've got religion right
well yes yes to a certain degree as
we're going to see
the second part is ethical action human
and divine knowledge guilt and
destiny or fate right and then the third
part legal status now the third part
legal status where we have a lord of the
world
which is you know actually referencing
the unhappy consciousness section
in that section um and and you know the
stoicism and skepticism sections as well
hegel doesn't talk about that at all
instead he focuses on these
two sections so if there's divine
knowledge there's got to be some
engagement with god right
well yes and no what does hegel have to
say here
he tells us that in the ethical world we
did see a religion the religion
of the underworld it is the belief
in the terrible unknown night of faith
and in the humanities
of the departed spirit so let's pause on
that for
just a moment you know there there are
different aspects of ancient greek
religion which he's taking as as
characteristic here
which is typical hegel right you know
the greeks are sort of like the
embodiment of western
rationality which is the embodiment of
rationality as such the development of
spirit
so you know the romans take a lot of
stuff from the greek so even when hegel
moves from the greeks to the romans
there's still this this aspect there of
you know we need to focus on on what the
greeks were doing so the greeks had
you know the pantheon of the olympian
gods who had displaced the titans
and you know there's a belief in in the
haitian underworld and
all that sort of stuff and then there is
this other aspect of greek religion
and we're not just talking about say
like the mystery religions we're also
talking about something that's practiced
within the home
and acknowledged as important within
the city but there's always a rivalry
between the city's laws and the divine
laws as as we've seen like again in the
antigone
so the greeks believed in what we can
call the catholian
gods those who very often you're not
praying to because you want them to help
you out
or their ideals you actually want to
keep them away and you want to appease
them
and satisfy them and you do things in
the dark
and you do things out of motives for
them so this is what we're talking about
here
right and he brings up fate and he
brings up the
humanities of the departed spirit now
interestingly
the spirit here is not just a shade as
he's going to talk about
chata in just a bit shadow but a spirit
a geist
he's using the word geist there so we'd
think okay that's great we've got the
development of spirit
and um what does he mean by humanities
well these are what what we
called um other things
you know to euphemize them
you know we don't want to speak ill of
the dead they say
right so why not well because maybe the
dead are listening
and they don't like the way we talk
about them so we have to propitiate
them so he goes on and he says this is
religion
right but what kind of religion do we
have
well let's think about these objects of
the religion
the former fate is pure negativity
in the form of universality so it is
universal
but it's it's a kind of negativity he
says
the latter is the same negativity in the
form of individuality
absolute being he says in the latter
form
that is in the departed dead
is uh is in the latter form indeed the
self and present since other than
present the self cannot be
so the dead are with us the dead are
acknowledged by us
right but how are they he says
the individual self is this individual
shade
shadow which is separated from itself
the universality which fate is right so
we got two different kinds of
universality
going on here as he's going to tell us
true it's a shade a
superseded alpha hobness you know so
it's been transcended
particular self and thus a universal
self
so let me pause on this for a moment
when people die you know we
we allow them to like live in our hearts
as we say
but it's it's a memory of them or it's a
reconstruction of them or an
idealization of them
it's not them as them as a acting living
subject it's them as a universal subject
but as a
you know sublated or overcome subject so
he goes on and he says
the negative significance of the shade
has not still changed round into the
positive significance of the universal
self that's what we're looking for
so the supersede itself still has at the
same time the immediate significance
of this particular and essenceless being
but fate devoid of self remains the
unconscious knight which is not attained
to an imminent differentiation
so you know neither side is really
satisfying for what we're looking for
for religion
the departed spirit the sacred dead
they have not changed into the positive
significance of the universal self
they have the immediate significance of
this particular and essenceless being
when we walk through somebody else's
graveyard
there's a sense in which we don't care
unless we you know are worried about you
know like zombies arising or
the evil dead or whatever it's going to
be all that sort of silly supernatural
uh just for for uh entertaining
ourselves
fantasies that we bring up in a certain
sense the dead
as the dead only matter to those who
continue to
remember them at least in in this
particular way that hegel is thinking
about it there are in fact
plenty of cultures in which the
ancestors have a much more robust
capacity to be involved but that's not
what he's
he's talking about here what about fate
fate is devoid of self
there isn't any self there there's
there's really almost no self on the
part of the departed spirit
there's no self in fate it's just what
it is
so it's as he calls it the unconscious
night which does not attain to an
imminent
differentiation nor to the clarity of
self-knowledge
how could fate attain to the clarity of
self-knowledge it doesn't even have an
intellect it doesn't have
an anything to it it just is
what it is and unfolds the way it does
so this is not getting us
religion in the sense that we're
developing it in this section
it does have you know all sorts of
implications for how the ancients
and perhaps many other people even
perhaps in the present
do view religious objects but for hegel
these are kind of
deficient and defective inadequate to
what religion really is for us human
beings
you